je vous trouve en pleine forme pour
battre h messieurs merci paddington tu
crois que chic et l'âge exact groupe à
81,4
au moins un petit ours jeter un oeil
l'animal est de retour aux molaires dans
une nouvelle grande aventure
enfin jacques cresta vous attend mais ce
n'est pas moi le voleur ce noël paix tu
nous donnes revient au cinéma que la
chasse comme excusez moi mais si la cote
si je veux toucher un mot sur la
nourriture on pourrait ajouter un peu de
sauce qu'elle casser ce qui marche pour
le catch à paddington n'hésiterai pas
une seconde il a nous avait besoin
d'être battue comme sa lolita à l'apport
addington c'est déjà fantastique genre
qu'ils habitent vous voulez bien nous
excuser mais on ne peut pas se fier à
des types comme eux mais regarde les
enfin regarde ce grand babouins barbu
qui est au milieu il doit avoir à peine
deux neurones dans sa boîte crânienne
on vous entend toujours badine tonnes de
au cinéma le 6 décembre